dans une réaction commune sans précédent
la quasi-totalité des partis politiques
et groupe parlementaires des parlements
français et européens se sont tous
retrouvés pour contester la nomination
par la Commission européenne de Fiona
Scott Morton comme chef économiste à la
direction générale de la concurrence
cette bronca n'est en aucun cas une
remise en cause du brillant parcours
universitaire de cette professeur de
Yelle mais celle de son activité de
lobbyiste pour Amazon Apple au Microsoft
entre autres et de son tropisme avéré en
faveur des grandes sociétés nous n'avons
pas là le profil d'une future
fonctionnaire au service de l'Union
européenne mais bien plutôt d'un conflit
d'intérêt latent cette nomination
intervient dans un contexte d'adaptation
par le Parlement de notre droit national
des digital marketact et digital
services Isaac dérèglements européens
qui prévoit de limiter la domination
économique des grandes plateformes et la
diffusion en ligne de contenu et de
produits illicite parler d'un fâcheux
hasard tient de l'euphémisme
couvrons ce conflit d'intérêt que nous
ne saurions voir semble dire la
commission qui pour sauver sa décision
propose que la nouvelle chef économiste
se met en retrait de sa mission chaque
fois qu'un conflit intéresse annoncera
la majeure partie des sujets qui seront
être traités concernent les gafams on
peut ainsi s'interroger sur la
crédibilité d'un tel choix sur l'intérêt
de placer un tel fonction une personne
qui ne pourra de toute façon que très
partiellement l'exercer madame la
ministre le groupe démocrate ne comprend
pas cette nomination l'Europe n'a-t-elle
pas la capacité à trouver en son sein
parmi 447 millions de personnes une
compétence digne de ce poste ainsi nous
souhaitons savoir comment vous envisagez
madame la ministre de convaincre la
Commission européenne de revenir sur
cette